هل تعتقد على المدى الطويل أن هذا الفيروس موجود
ليبقى
الآن وإذا كان الأمر كذلك ، فماذا سيكون الأمر
أعني هل سيكون هذا شيئًا
نخوضه في معركة مع كل موسم مثل
الأنفلونزا هل
سيكون له نفس النوع من الوفيات
و  عندما تفكر
فيك ، تعرف تاريخك الطويل مع فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية (HIV) و (
tb um) ،
حيث ترى كيف يبدو covet 19
في تشكيلة
الأمراض المعدية هل سيكون أسوأ قاتل لنا
الآن أو لفترة طويلة ، فأنت تعرف أين سيهبط
رقم II  أنت تعلم أنه من
الصعب التنبؤ بالتنبؤ ببيتسي ، لكنني سأقول إنني
لا أعتقد أنه سيكون في النهاية
أسوأ قاتل لنا
لأن الكثير من الناس يعانون من عدوى بدون أعراض من
20 إلى 45 في المائة من الناس ،
فمن المؤكد أنها قاتلة لأولئك الذين
هم
كبار السن وأولئك الذين يعانون من
ظروف أساسية
في بعض الأحيان يكون لديك استثناء
لدينا شخص شاب
يتمتع بصحة جيدة يعاني من مرض خطير
للغاية ويموت ،
وهذا أقلية من ذلك ، لكنني لا
أرى هذا
يختفي بالطريقة التي اختفى بها
سارس  السبب في أنني أقول ذلك هو أنه
فعال للغاية
في قدرته على الانتقال من
إنسان إلى آخر ،
وأعتقد أننا في نهاية المطاف
سنتحكم فيه.
درجة من المناعة العالمية للقطيع
ولقاح جيد ، وأنا
آمل وأشعر بتفاؤل حذر بأننا
سوف أفكر عندما تضع هؤلاء الثلاثة
معًا ،
أعتقد أننا سنحصل على سيطرة جيدة جدًا على
هذا
سواء كان هذا العام أو العام المقبل.
لست متأكدًا ولكني أعتقد في النهاية أنه
مع مزيج من تدابير الصحة العامة
الجيدة ولقاح
قد لا نقضي عليه ، لكنني أعتقد
أننا سننزله إلى مستوى منخفض
لدرجة أننا لن نكون في الموقف الذي
نحن فيه  الآن
لفترة طويلة من الزمن